what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
hello everybody welcome welcome welcome
this is really just we need to help you
raise your hand and i'll come in and try
to help who's got
a question a scenario a challenge that
uh could use some perspective on all
right denise is in the house what do we
got denise
all right i'm going to challenge myself
with this zan challenged me so i'm gonna
speak my uh my knees i love it let's go
this is great
so i um at the beginning stages i
actually just started with the movement
makers in march and
have been blogging for a year
so what i'm trying to do is to gain some
momentum in terms of my voice my you
know what i want to share is my mission
and translate that into a video forum so
i've done it i've
kind of touched a little bit of
everything so i've touched a little bit
in um i the ig world i've done reels
i've done a couple of lives with other
movement makers
i've um touched on tick tock and now it
kind of
coincides with the conversation earlier
this morning now i'm just trying to
figure out my
method
without burning myself out because i'm
my focus is work-life balance by the way
yeah burning myself out and teaching
some opposite
kind of how do i start folding in all of
these different things you mentioned
earlier you have a team of 42 i'm yet a
i'm still a solopreneur you know with
just a team of ones so i'm trying to
figure out the best way
in a practical way being new to creating
video
of being able to translate things out in
the way that you suggested um because
i'm new to understanding the video
world in terms of how to best edit and
and what have you so when i hear take a
10 minute and chop it in i'm still like
whoa that still sounds like a lot so um
but i don't know if you have any advice
with regards to streamlining that
process maybe i'm making it bigger than
what i needed to be yeah well let's
let's dive in and then listen the
beginning
it it always feels bigger than it is
and and it is kind of big because you
don't have the skills yet but as you
develop the skills as you get started it
ends up being a lot easier just just
like any other skill like when i first
learned a snowboard i fell down 50 times
on the way down the hill and now i can
go down without falling down right just
like anything else um let's start with
this what do you want to sell so you say
you talk about work-life balance what
what is our business what do we sell
my goal is to coach but ironically i
want to coach people to be able to coach
themselves
so so i don't want to necessarily put
myself out of business but i feel like
if people really learn their way to
internalize
um their method for being able to live
work like balance they shouldn't need a
coach for their life they should be able
to be the coach for their life so that's
ultimately um where i want to get them
to but initially they may need to coach
and that's what i'm here for so and the
blog and and what have you speaks to
that as well it's it's another forum to
be able to say how do i get information
independently
when i'm trying to do things you know on
my own great and the coaching do you see
it as being a one-on-one thing is it a
group coaching is it like a six-week
program with you where they learn
everything how are you envisioning it
long-term i would like to be able to do
courses that's what i would i feel like
i would enjoy um but i'll be honest i
have come out of this is new for me i've
been almost 20 years in the hr world and
in that world i always had someone come
into my office and i'm coaching them
one-on-one so i'm very accustomed to
doing that and then also doing
like courses well in that form it would
be more training
groups small groups new leaders things
of that nature and helping them as well
and work-life balance always came into
those forums so no matter what you came
in whatever that you know the the worry
or your mind was that boss that you
couldn't stand too much work on your on
your plate
it always came back to work-life balance
and so i i feel like i have a lot of
content to lean on in terms of my back
background in the world that i lived
before
and so i'm just trying to you know
translate that into these this new
mechanism
so coaching was what i was
after
are you already coaching or this is a
new business that we're trying to create
it's a new business and because i've
always done my prior world is nine to
five right so it's a new business in
terms of um having something outside of
that forum in order to explore um but
it's greenfield so i'll say that this is
my thought coming out the gate
but um but as i continue to explore and
and find out new things in terms of the
entrepreneur world um i honestly i start
branching out and sometimes i got to
bring myself back in so so i don't know
well listen i love it this is great and
you're great on camera this is awesome
you haven't even started making you know
the real videos this is great
i love it so i'd look at two things to
be honest the first is actually doing
coaching videos so we're doing it right
now this is a coaching video
okay we just be flipped
where you have people come on like so
you know who doesn't deal with work-life
balance issues
you know at some point in their life but
probably every day right so you can help
tons of people
and
all you have to do is show up so when i
came on here
i'm like okay who's got a question guys
what are we going to talk about and
hopefully you asked me a question that i
you know can answer as opposed to you
know gardening or something that's gonna
ask nina to come in and help answer
uh so all you have to do is show up and
people are gonna say okay here's my
here's what i'm struggling with denise
right say how can i help and then you
help them and that becomes content and
the and the reason why they would come
on is because hiring you might be
expensive or they don't you know know
who you are yet and so they'll do it for
free
because they're going to get the
one-on-one coaching but the the
condition is that this is going to live
as a video
so then it becomes okay how do you find
people to be able to do coaching
sessions with that was immediately going
to be my question yeah
and i just did this with um
an entrepreneur i invested into her name
is kira polson and she's helping people
she helps pull books out of people um
she taught in movement makers
yeah about a month ago
were you in that session i was oh it was
an amazing experience oh my goodness
cool okay
so she i mean i invested into her
company i'm a 25 you know owner of
helping her build her publishing company
up and
as a part of that i said okay you love
doing these sessions with people make
them public and so now what she's doing
is a five times a week show on instagram
where she's helping pull books out of
people
so if you went on you'd be like okay
denise like let's let's tap into your
book and she'd go through her process
and your book would flow out of you just
like it did for me and
um
i wrote my book 40 000 words in five
days and a member in movement makers
today said he just started with her and
he wrote his first 800 words
this morning before movement makers
started and movie maker starts at 10 30
at least on the east coast and he
already got 800 words done today it's
like let's go this is working
um and so it's
now she has his daily show where she had
nothing going on before
so
she gets people from
people who are already following her
from
doing events and then saying hey can you
can you do you want to come on and join
me live so
if you're on instagram already how many
followers you have on instagram right
now
oh not uh i'll say 50 plus
50 perfect so those are those are 50
people that you can send a video message
to to say hey i'm starting a new show
you don't need a thousand people or or a
hundred thousand people or a million
people or whatever you send a dm a video
dm
i like doing them while i'm outside
walking
um have you gotten have you gotten a
video for me at all ever
i haven't i have no not yet okay what
really you're moving makers and you
haven't got a video dm for me
i haven't
i mean i didn't i didn't i didn't take
it as a
connection i should have by now i mean
when how long have you been in movie
makers
march we just started march and it's
july i'm gonna i'm gonna message my team
and see why have i not sent a message to
denise
no pressure connor maybe we're not
following are we following you on
instagram maybe it's um maybe it's
because it's under my business name it's
under curvy points is my
favorite points
i'm going to look at this one so i'm
anonymous maybe that's why i gotta look
this up you're anonymous your own
account is anonymous no no it's not
i mean it doesn't say denise so curvy
points
i'm not even following you
anyway well i'm gonna follow you right
now
so somewhere in there is a message that
got lost but
um yeah so you have 55 55 i'm your 55th
way to go right and so you've got you've
got
a lot of people so you've got you know a
bunch of mover makers already following
you you dm everybody video message i'd
like to do my so why we can guidance i
like i like to do my video message when
i'm outside
so i'm walking in the morning and i'll
message people
um and she's saying i'm starting a new
show
coaching people on work-life balance
if you'd like to be a guest it's free
i'm starting whatever wednesday
noon
eastern whatever
do you want to be a guest on the show
and it's free i'm going to coach you
whatever you need help with
and it's a that's usually the easiest
now you're already great on camera
you say that and i have such
camera phobia
you i won't even i'll take up all day if
i start talking about my camera phobia
but thank you
well i mean i i am too before i film
and i've done
i don't know 15 000 videos or something
but the key is you just you just go
and like you just did it now you raised
your hand and you just started talking
and it was great you're eloquent you put
together she's got a message it's like
it's clear easy to understand it's great
um so now it's just about a press record
but it's a lot easier when you're with
somebody and you're coaching so you
don't even need you don't need them to
have um you don't need to know in
advance what you're going to talk about
it's going to be something more like
work-life balance yeah but you don't
need them to answer 20 questions before
they come and go live with you you just
say how can i help
and it's the easiest kind of content to
make and
more importantly it also helps build
your coaching business because now i get
to see you coach
yeah so
um
yeah zane's a coach right he's the
built-in the only bill to serve coach
certified
the only mom the only momentum certified
coach as well
uh which is great let's go zan
uh and as much as zane zhang can go and
do framework videos
you know the
spell out confidence of the three c's of
confidence great but if you wanted to
gross coaching practice you know the
best content they make is actually
coaching content like let's see somebody
come in who doesn't have confidence they
spend time with zane and then their eyes
get
blown open like oh my gosh i didn't even
know that thank you zan so same thing
for you somebody's feeling stressed out
overwhelmed doesn't know how to handle
their work their
their career their home their husband
their wife their kids it's like all just
insane overwhelm i can't deal
and then they talk to you and they have
hope
you know for the first not even like a
strategy yes but even like hope that
they don't have to stay stuck anymore
because
you listen to them and you give them
what they needed in that moment
other people watching then will feel
like oh wow like maybe i can
maybe i should work with denise or maybe
i should be a guest on her show
and then is the next step to that and
maybe it's just such a basic question
then just having
that lead then in the in the profile in
the bio just to say hey if you if you
also want to
enjoy a coaching session this is how you
sign up with me kind of thing something
so simple
or is it better to have a little bit
more of an enticement of a um
a guy independent guide an assessment
you can do on your own or something like
that before it's time to take it too
this is a two-step process
like you can't let perfect be the enemy
of
momentum so there's a perfect way to do
it perfect great but but it doesn't mean
zero until we get there
yeah so step number one is
just a coaching length if you want to be
coached by me or you want to be a guest
on my show dm me
okay you can do that today you know like
easy update that you know how to do that
you don't need some technical person to
come in and help you update your
instagram bio all right so you can put
that in great and that's a fantastic
start does your bio even say that you're
a coach
i'm going to say it says i'm a blogger
probably
yeah i'm sure yeah
i'm 1000 sure what it says so curvy
points blogger follow us if you're a
busy working woman looking to transform
your life and gain clarity focus
direction inner peace
yeah and then there's a link
and where does the link go to the link
goes to your latest blog and oh just
i'll blog
and then some spotify playlists
so i just think you're a blogger like i
don't know that you're a coach yeah
you'd have to go onto my
you'd have to go into my website and see
that i have a service page that that has
coaching listed
which is so there's a lot of steps to
get there i see that now instantaneously
i see that that's great well hey we're
adding more clarity and focus right now
this is great yeah we're doing it and
that's what coaching does right you're
you shine a spotlight on another people
and where they need to
improve so same thing here like instead
of a blogger we're a coach and
you you help people whatever it is help
people if you still want to do busy
working women cool
yeah deal with work-life balance issues
like
coaching on instagram and dm me you know
something like that that you put in
there
um
so that we start building our profile up
that's that's today
that's the next step that's easy right
like you can do that that's not
overwhelming
the perfect step would be to have some
kind of lead magnet
that you're capturing email addresses
for
so
you create a pdf
do you do you already have a pdf or
bonus or something people can download
um the only thing i've made thus far
just because it's been more commonly
brought to me is a a quick pdf on
building up your resume differently so i
do have that already crafted um but
that's just because that's usually what
honestly most people come to me for it's
not so much work-life balance where
they're they're suffering from a lack of
it and feel like the job is the source
of it and then looking to you know
change jobs right so most of the
coaching clients i have have been there
and so therefore i created a pdf really
for them that i also could use as a lead
magnet but um it doesn't have to
necessarily be the one that i
use for this form do you have any blog
articles i'm just looking at your ig now
do you have any blog articles on
work life balance
um so i so the way that i've i
structured it i don't have one
specifically just on work life balance
alone
um i have what i consider to be three
pillars right so one is the fact that
self-care as a priority
secondly is is with regards to a dream
dream job as possible
and thirdly that um it's it's practical
to have a work-life balance lifestyle so
self-care dream job
and the balanced life
lifestyle or the three pillars so all of
my articles
tend to fall under one of those pillars
and so they're different subjects but
they all lead back to work-life balance
your articles are no joke like you're
writing yeah right
no no but like
i've been hiding in the veil of writing
and not speaking
well but sometimes a blogger like you do
200 words and you have a blog post like
you're you're you're legit like that's
great so here's here's the easy thing to
do if you have your three pillars cool
you take some of your
your existing blog articles
and smush them together into a guide
oh okay okay
so the one i clicked on was how to feel
how to feel your soul in life
how to feel your soul in life and at
work so i don't that's a recent one or
just the one i clicked on
so so that's that's like one so if you
had your seven steps or your eight tips
or your three ways to
achieve work-life balance this becomes
one of them so this is how step number
one feel your soul in life and at work
and then you bring that article in
and then you picked two to seven more
from stuff you've already written
yeah and you
that's your guide okay okay
so now you've got it now you've got like
that's an ebook almost you've got a you
know 30 page book there um yeah and you
don't have to then sit down and write it
from scratch
so because it's a because it's a lead
magnet i'll say a freebie
because i always
suffer with most of my content
everywhere i put it is brand new like
you see something on my ig page you're
never going to see it duplicate it twice
and it won't be duplicated anywhere and
that's that's that sounds great but it's
you know yeah you know slightly it's
messing up my work-life balance
and it's just not and like candidly it's
not smart because like the ability to
repurpose the content
is a huge lever point you have zero
leverage in your business because
everything has to be hand done from
scratch yes yes where
your best quotes from your blog articles
should become
ig pictures and and tweets okay you're
like for sure
yeah you you repurposing because
even people who have first off
you could you might be concerned oh but
people may have read it already
right okay one like most people don't
read all your stuff
right you haven't seen all my videos
most people don't watch all my videos
we're not that important right like
people if you're how many blogs some
people subscribe to tons
and second just because they've read it
doesn't mean they still don't need the
message
yeah so you're saying somebody reads
what somebody's going to read this
article every not somebody everybody's
going to read this article you wrote on
lining up your life
they're going to read it once and then
that's it their life is going to be lit
up and they never need another reminder
ever again right i mean you know we're
yeah we're laughing but that's
that's basically the mindset we're
adopting was no people need that
reminder
even if they have heard it before which
most people won't because we're trying
to bring in new people but even on the
off chance that they have seen it before
the thing zen has up behind him i've
talked about that like eight times in
movement makers
you know and it's still valuable and
it's still a reminder and this every
time like there's still one more thing
that you have to
you have to remember
i'm so glad that you're saying what
you're saying because again only being
in the group for a few months
um i'll be honest even the last session
you might not like to hear this but the
last session i was like i don't think i
can go because i if i take him one more
idea
i'm going to explode
i don't know how do i put into practice
all this data i'm getting and i think to
your point it's because i'm not
necessarily
utilizing what i have in an efficient
way in order to make it practical the
things that i'm learning
each session so i did i had to take a
break like after i think here was last
one and you didn't want him in between
i'm like
you just need a mental health thing
there's only so much movement this maker
can make
i mean i appreciate the honesty and i
appreciate you showing up here and and
raising your hand and asking a question
because you know a lot of people
when they're struggling do feel
overwhelmed then do quit and give up
where the answer is just build a little
bit of momentum
yeah so in any training whether it's
mine or anybody else's it's like take
one piece and just do something on it
like if you help somebody with a
work-life balance and you create
an entire beautiful life for them
the path to get there feels overwhelming
and daunting and impossible and
true maybe the next step is okay like
just
take 20 minutes a day to breathe
yeah or just go have that one
conversation with your husband or just
like put up a little bit of the defense
at work
or just like
you it's amazing to think about the life
they could build but we're stuck
in the how and it's just so overwhelming
that then they do nothing
yeah and so the most important thing is
just the momentum to build up that's why
we're doing the
momentum challenge coming up because
it's more most people are stuck even
achievers is where you're stuck
um
so yeah so the coaching
series
yep
ideally leads to a lead magnet
making lead magnets easy because you
already have all the content you just
gotta package it together
and then that's where
once you have your email address you can
do a lot more that's where you can
promote your coaching that's where if
you need more guests for your show
that's where if you have like when i
have my momentum challenge came up we're
going to email people
who've watched my videos who've
downloaded my lead magnets so that they
know about the challenge that's coming
up
if if we go from
instagram video or coaching session
right to dm me
it's almost like you're getting married
on the first date
right which which will happen like some
people will just do it because they need
it they love what they're ready but most
people
don't want to take that biggest step at
the beginning they're like oh denise
okay i like her vibe who is she oh she's
got this free thing okay let me go check
that out before i'm gonna commit to
coming on even if you think about you
showing up here
you're in movement makers you've been
here since march so we're like months in
now
you're
you've seen my stuff and know me but
it's like if zan didn't push you would
you have raised your hand that quickly
absolutely not absolutely not
right
so but so like one yay for zayn let's
like collect people and and it's great
to be around people who who push you to
want to be better
but now imagine people watching your
stuff
there's that
resistance to dming you where they might
have to watch a few of your episodes
first they'd be like oh i don't know
what you're dm her or not you know i'm
struggling but i don't know
just hammering and hein right yeah and
so the way to shortcut that is instead
of having them to have to dm you to get
the free
pdf bonus but then you can build the
relationship through email
send them send them valuable video send
them content
build the know like trust like denise is
the woman for me she can help me okay
now i'll come on her show
so that's
that's the perfect that's the ideal that
we're building towards is some kind of
lead magnet capture but
today
we update our bio and say
yeah that's it dm me
yeah
and then and then for the content
um i would mix in both coaching even
when i said today in movie makers you
have one
ig live per
a week
so ideally you're doing like a coaching
session at least once some of the
movements go live every day which works
too but
again let's not overwhelm ourselves and
you know stress out
but one ig live coaching per week
and then one video per week of you
sharing
some of your methodologies some of the
things you've learned
even if you don't cut it up and put it
through their platforms yet even if you
just post it on youtube because the
first ones it took me two days to make
one video at the beginning
now i i didn't have a mentor i
overthought everything i was in my suit
and you know i had to memorize
everything and yeah but
but you it'll become faster as you put
in more repetition just like anything
else yeah so
it may
feel impossible to make
10 videos in a day right now
but you'll be able to get there
yeah and it won't take as much time
right like 10 videos might take you 10
days to make right now
yeah so it feels like there's no way i
can overcome that hurdle
but
so don't stress about it because as you
get better at it and you figure out the
skill sets
and you got family supporting you and
you know we're here to cheer you on and
give you love community and like post
movement makers um
then it'll become a lot faster so as a
starting point just
book book a guest for your show reach
out send send the video dms
update your instagram bio yeah and even
that
like it's it's momentum
and that feels like a big step and it
looks that's a that's a huge step that's
a huge step and worth like you know high
high-fiving yourself or like pat
yourself on the back you took that huge
step it's amazing
and
after that huge step is once you get
used to that it's like okay i'm ready
for my next step
yeah yeah i guess i made that also too
big in my mind because i had seen
someone some time ago
who um didn't coach well i guess there
was coaching they had open forum
questions uh you know people coming in
and thinking how in the world do you do
that how do you get people
to come in and they did they're slightly
different it was almost like a a phone
in session but they still did it um you
know via ig and i was just so confused
like how in the world i don't know
enough to know how to get
that opportunity but i feel like as
you've already mentioned
if anybody came and just had anything on
their heart with regards to work-life
balance even if they didn't see it as
that was the issue they had but i i have
complete confidence in myself that i'd
be able to identify and say hey and
let's talk through this and let me see
let me show you what i see let me listen
first and foremost but then as i'm
listening let me let me give you a
different view on it and i just was so
anxious to find that form because again
working in an hr office people just come
to you i don't have to do that you know
it just came they came in and asked for
a form and somehow we were having an
hour-long conversation about their life
so
to be able to translate that into an ig
forum i'm like i don't know how to do it
but i just so desperately feel like it
would be worthwhile to do and it will
get to the point where people will just
come
yeah and at the beginning
you you even me when i started my ig
live show i booked the first five guests
i messaged in person say hey i'm
starting a new show you want to be a
guest on my show
yeah coaching helping out whatever
problem you have around entrepreneurship
something i can answer for you
you know great i'm not coming in talking
about hair care products
[Laughter]
right so you know something i can help
with uh and then if you continue on it
it'll become its own thing where people
will want to come on
but you you book the first
guests and you say i'll be on tomorrow
at noon come join me
and even if it's just the two of you and
like nobody's watching yet cool like
you're still helping that one person and
it's still valuable and it still gives
you content that you can use for years
and it's it's it's a human like you're
still going to add value you're going to
pour into this other human who's
struggling with something right now and
they're going to get value from it
and it'll still feel good because now
it's like i help somebody today yeah
yeah just the whole point
let's go denise we love you thank you
appreciate it thank you for sharing
thank you for raising your hand thank
you for sticking with it you know when
you
felt stressed out and maybe a little
overwhelmed and not sure what to do next
there's usually a topic and then we dive
into q a today laura is here and so
laura had the winning question your
question was one word obstacles so why
don't you tell us a little bit first
about
the obstacles you're facing and then
let's make this um let's make this
content matter
okay
well thank you so much uh you're a role
model to me so your answers and
i mean you know this this is so critical
for me so obstacles and i'm right in the
beginning of the book evan and i'm in
the middle of the first really that
finding out my who i'm still there um
and i and i'm encountering all sorts of
obstacles and i'm a
tony robbins person i have
i follow his advice on obstacles but i
still seem to be struggling with this
where
in other words i'm working on i have a
full-time job and working on a uh my
business that i eventually want to be my
you know my everything but i'm finding
that there are so many distractions that
they become these obstacles and i'm
having trouble getting past them
to see my outcome and this is even with
with my reading of my book and spending
time in your book and and trying to
focus
these obstacles are taking over
and i'm i'm having trouble managing the
obstacles for example parents you know
aging parents and they're very very
needy helicopter parents and i i'm
trying boundaries but this is a big
obstacle for me that's my question i
love it no and listen man thank you for
thank you for showing up but thank you
for sharing and thank you for being
vulnerable that you know it's uh that's
a hard thing to do so i appreciate you
for doing that some of the obstacles are
you know our our own
resistance to things and we're afraid of
we're afraid you know it's like you're
afraid of doing the thing and so we find
a way to procrastinate you know like if
you're procrastinating on something it's
because
you either don't want to do the thing
you know you don't want to read my book
you know or you're or you're afraid
you're afraid of like what it may mean
and what changes may come
um and and
the path through procrastination is
really to figure out okay what's the
source because if it's that you really
don't want to do it then we need to find
a way to not be doing it long term
but if you
really do want to do it but you're just
afraid that the fear is not a good
enough reason anymore that we've
wrapped things up into a story that
we'll believe but really it's just fear
underneath it
fear of you launching your business fear
of it fear of it working out fear of it
not working out for the people will see
you feel the people won't see you it's
like we're afraid of both
and it's really just fear talking
there's ways around parents obviously
you can you can put away your phone you
can not have any connection to you you
want to read a book and you're afraid
about your parents cool you know go to a
park turn off your phone and go read
your book like there's there's solutions
around it but really it's identifying
what's the source of the fear
if it's
building your business
what are you so afraid of
inside that company
does prevent i'm assuming that you want
to do it that the procrastination isn't
because you know somebody else is
telling you to do it
you want to do it but you're afraid to
do it what is the actual fear that's
underlying
the procrastination
the fear is that i won't be able to be
there for my family i don't actually
live with them and they're and they're
old and my great great my grandparents
are actually
getting so old they're all struggling so
that it's such a very needy situation
and um
i know that when i'm successful as i've
i've been in the past few weeks leading
up till now
i was doing so good and then all of a
sudden um i was encountering this
obstacle with my family that i was
not being available as much that i was
so it's it's this
perhaps that's the fear is just not
being available and and
getting past that
that's that's the tough part yeah well
and how much of the things that they're
asking for are actually urgent versus
ones that are not really
100
not right okay right what's the zone of
their importance and and and priority
versus what's mine
everything is urgent to them it's been
like that and i'm learning now
to change how i react uh respond to
their urgencies so it's just you
feeling comfortable with the identity of
how do i be a great daughter
or or granddaughter or you know whoever
else that you're considering caring for
how do i how do i be that person and
build my business what does that look
like
and having a little bit of clarity
around that so does
taking you know today is a thursday
afternoon it's two o'clock on the east
coast for me this taking three to five
o'clock on a thursday afternoon to grow
your business whatever that means
whether you're doing emails or writing
your book or whatever that looks like
um and you turn your phone off does that
make you a bad
you know air quotes bad daughter or bad
granddaughter
no
but is you actually getting comfortable
with that that's like hey if if i am
because when you're showing up for them
you're also not fully committed to them
because you're thinking about the other
stuff you have to do
right right and now there's like this
extra layer of guilt and judgment that
you're they're partially to blame for
you not having more success on your
dreams than your business they're not
first lame but that's the story
right right charlotte's soccer
tournament right we love you charlotte i
gotcha i gotcha i hear you i hear you
all yeah it's like getting the amends
from the crowd yeah ice cream
right
now you're right but that's the story
like and then yeah you don't want to you
don't want to have resentment towards
them that oh now like i lost three years
of work in my business because i had to
care for them
so
it's about presence
there will be there will be true
emergencies
and so
you need to be there for true
emergencies but for most of these things
that don't matter right now
how can you create a schedule that
you're not judging it's not it's never
going to be good enough for them
right right so we have to let go of that
but but it's like
you need to live your own life so what
is that what is a happy life for you
where you're proud of yourself that you
can be an example
you know for the people in your like you
have kids
no okay for the example for the people
around you in your life
um
and also still be proud of the
being the
the daughter and granddaughter so that
when you're with them you're with them
right
that you're not thinking about the book
you should be reading or the calls you
should be making or the videos you
should be recording that you're actually
sitting there with them because you've
you've made that happen
wow yeah
yeah thank you
it's just the fear
you know it is uh and it's almost
it's like making uh
it is making business hours perhaps
right it's like making business hours
when i am available and not available so
that i can be available i got it mm-hmm
and and they may never fully understand
it
yeah like they probably won't you know
at this age they probably won't so
this is where it gets tough because it
becomes now it's
your job to be the adult in the
relationship
yeah which is right which is hard for
your parents or like grandparents
absolutely absolutely that's that's how
it's feeling it's feeling like i'm
becoming a
parent
now
okay yeah
so you know in parents
um you know i have a son like you don't
want to spend all day long with your
with your kids you don't want to spend
all day long with your spouse you don't
want to spend all day long with your
grandparents you don't spend all day
long in your business either
and and there's the
um
the judgment as to where you should
spend time in which bucket
is personal because everybody will have
an opinion on what you should do with
your life right yeah your your mom and
grandparents will have a they'll they
will have their opinion like you need to
do this laura with your life
but it's not what you want to do
not fully it's a piece of it so what is
what does laura's version of her life
look like
and it actually allows you to show up as
a better
daughter
and granddaughter as well because you're
more present when you're with them
i mean and it's been some of that may
change like if if one of them actually
gets really sick
yeah and it becomes urgent
then
now maybe you put your business goals
like if if my mom suddenly had to go to
the hospital like if she had some career
nina had to go to the hospital for
something um
i would be okay with not being as
productive in my business
right i'm okay like that's an easy
that's an easy trade
we had a movement makers one of the only
times i missed movie makers was because
15 minutes before we were going live
nina sliced her finger open on a blender
she was trying to clean the blender and
she turned it on and we won't go into
like too much details but like
blood everywhere and that's like i'm
about to go live like i've got my
community people are paying to be here
i'm about to go live it's like
just yelling and hear from the from the
thing right from the kitchen i come out
blood is everywhere like okay we're
going to the hospital it's like no no
i'll drive myself like are you kidding
first off like nina's amazing but you're
not driving with this with that there's
no way i'm taking you it's like what
about movement makers i don't know we'll
figure it out
so i get in the car and we start driving
i call my friend mark and say hey mark
do you have any could you talk about
clubhouse because clubhouse is popping
at the time can you come in and do a
presentation nobody's ever subbed in for
me for any of the stuff that i was doing
but can you can you please you know do
this do you have any you have anything
ready to go he said yeah happy to do it
no problem um
and he ran a great show and everybody
asked some great questions and and i
wasn't allowed to go into the hospital
because of covert rules at the time so i
sat in the car and i joined in and
listened in
um but but whatever even if it didn't
work out like even if even if i had no
show you know zayn who's in here was
getting the party started he's like okay
guys we're ready get ready to have evan
come on we're gonna do this thing and
then like there's mark
you know zayn evan's not there but in
the worst case i could have said
hey guys i can't make it i'm taking you
to the hospital
and some people may not have been happy
with that some people may maybe they
leave movement makers because of that
maybe they were so excited like they
paid their money and like i didn't show
up
i'm okay with that trade-off right
because taking nina to the hospital
to fix now she's okay and we i still got
stitches and like
didn't lose her thumb or anything so it
all worked out but um
all that matters is what you feel
some people may have judged me and said
hey nope no good like i'm out cool we
may have lost some customers there
maybe some people thought i didn't spend
enough time with her you know i don't
know but all that matters is how do i
feel about myself with how i'm showing
up for things that i care about so my
balance between being a husband and
being a father and being an entrepreneur
is my balance you don't have to be me
but you have to do you
and everybody will have their opinion on
what you should do
so it's just
getting personal clarity and spending
more time with yourself just to figure
that out like how do i show up and be a
great daughter and granddaughter and
entrepreneur what does that balance look
like and things may throw you off but
you want the
actual emergencies like the blender and
the finger to throw you off as opposed
to
oh i don't know i'm
hungry let me drop everything and come
over and make you an outlet because
you're hungry
right yeah and
you know not to judge
you have to be the ultimate judge of
that situation right
um but but you can do it
you know and they may not fully
understand it or they won't fully
understand it or support it but it's
your your life is not
being lived to make other people happy
it's to figure out what makes you happy
thank you evan that's it the timing of
this is incredible because here i am in
the chapter what makes you happy and
you know i'm really i was sitting with
it and i rewrote it three or four times
honestly and i kept saying there's some
what is going on and it's really that
question just came to me and this was
exactly what i needed to determine all
these parts of what makes me happy
well there you go well thank you for
thank you thank you for posting it thank
you for writing the one word obstacles
and and then coming and sharing your
story we got uh susan in the house
susan's got her hand up what do we got
susan
hi evan i'm so happy to be talking to
you the last time i was on i
you you were gone before i could ask any
questions but actually
i wanna
it's i'm gonna pivot on what you were
just talking about okay
okay i'm 77 years old and
i have obviously
i have people i know for
a really really long time
and in this last
uh
couple of months there's been a huge
shift in me
i'm very very different
and
a couple of people maybe more but two
people i'm thinking of right now
they're friends they're not family their
friends
are really
reacting
they're reacting to the change
and it's negative to them well one of
them i'm actually going to see one of
the i mean one is in new york i i'm in
new york too i do see her um but but
most strikingly actually is a woman that
i'm going to be with um in florida
because there's a memorial for her
her dad's passing so i'm going to be
spending like five days with her i
haven't been with her we haven't you
know seen each other in person
in years
and we talk a lot on the phone but she's
expressed you're different i don't like
the way you've changed
there's something about you it's just so
different but the way she says it
and her irritability around it
like she's much more
nervous like she's
i don't know i feel like she's she
thinks i'm attacking her when i
i'm i'm not attack my essence is the
same you know yeah my essence is the
same my availability
is different
and i have confidence in myself
for the first time i have to say to
everybody on here and you that i have
never
felt
so in concert with myself
like i am i'm my best friend now
and i never felt that way in 70
nearly 77 years so
i'm not in danger of anybody
i'm going to cry actually but
i'm not ending anybody taking out my
demi my light
i just don't want other people to think
that i'm dimming theirs in some way
yeah and listen so this is something
everybody goes through everybody here
can relate to it if you're on a path of
growth and development and journey as an
entrepreneur you naturally want to help
others and especially the people closest
to you like how many times you've gone
to an event and you learn something like
oh you got to learn this thing
right and it comes from a beautiful
place the challenge is
it gets interpreted as judgment
because of their insecurity has nothing
to do with you you're giving love but
they see it as judgment because they're
insecure but where they're at they don't
like where they're at now they're
comparing themselves to you and you used
to be close in
success and now that you're doing more
and you're happier now that makes them
feel worse about yourself
so i mean as soon as you came on he's
like i love all the i love all the
papers behind you you're like you're
writing your goals out i see a healthy
routine on the board like all of these
white sheets i think it's amazing
all that stuff is back there no it's
great just like
susan's getting it this is fantastic
the key thing to think about there is um
you have to find a point if you want the
relation to continue
you have to find a point that you still
can connect on
and
don't worry about them
being happy for you
for the things that you're off and doing
um
i was
i was meeting with an entrepreneur
recently
and um he was going back he's having
trouble at home and he met with me to
talk about his business and i gave him a
lot of advice like oh my god this is
amazing and he's going back home
and he had more follow-up that he wanted
to ask me about and he's got
you know multiple kids at home he's got
his wife they're already on the rocks
like before he left
and
now you know his wife is looking after
the kids well he's on this trip to meet
me and i said you know what the best
thing you can do as you go home now is
don't go home all excited and talking
about how you met me and all the energy
and all these ideas that are coming
because what's going on
in her head
in her head is
i've just spent the last x days looking
after all these kids and doing well you
are off having fun there you come right
just like meeting them where they're at
and it feels really counter-intuitive
but the best if you actually want to
serve her the best thing you can do is
just listen to her
and talk about the things that
she cares about
and and don't push
and don't talk about what you're doing
unless she asks
and inside of that ultimately what will
happen is eventually there'll be some
kind of window
you need to eliminate the judgment and
again you are not actually judging her
but she feels judgment
she feels her own insecurity is being
projected from you
and so she attacks
instead of
being open she's not ready yet but she
could be
if she if she doesn't feel the judgment
she feels safe
and then she sees what you're up to
eventually what's going to happen how
are you doing that susan like how do you
how are you
talking about having a healthy routine
like making all these things on your
wall and like now you have confidence in
yourself
right because if you go in and it's
naturally we want to share
if you share here we love you we support
you like you see like what's happening
in the chat but if you go back to your
friend who've been known for decades and
say i'm i actually have confidence now
that i've never had ever in my life
she'd be like who does this susan think
she is
[Music]
because your friend doesn't have
confidence
and so it requires being the bigger
person and unless we all have this
whether it's our friends whether it's
our family
the hardest one is if it's your spouse
you know because that's that's a
the inability to grow together i mean
they think that's what ultimately makes
the relationship is like can you grow
together not who you are now but who can
you continue to be
ongoing um but friends and family
is just sitting there being with them
and just spending time with her so and
now especially if she lost her father i
mean holy she's dealing with
i can't imagine losing my dad i mean
it's gonna happen at some point but i
can i i don't expect myself to show up
as my most kind empathetic listening
caring person
you know if my dad
yeah thank you actually for saying that
just even just that i mean everything
you said
really really helpful to me
but that last thing about i can't even
imagine you know
you know you're not you can't imagine
how you'd be
i have to keep that i have to keep that
in mind and
and really be open to
her
anxiety and her nervousness and her
impatience and
and all of that and i
yeah
i do tend to say too much to her about
what i'm doing because i love to share
with her but i understand your point
it's so much better things that she's
comfortable receiving like be be
cognizant of of and it
it feels
bad to have to dim your own light to be
around friends
and as long as it's not impacting you
negatively like as long as she doesn't
pull you down it's finding connection
points there's hopefully some things you
can talk about that have nothing to do
with the new venture that you're on that
still brings a lot of joy like
um
you know i went to a funeral not too
long ago where
a friend of mine her father passed and
everybody came and uh shared a story
about her father
so like tell me this basically tell me a
story about my dad that i don't know or
even that i do know that you want it so
it became this kind of happy joyful more
of a life celebration because he didn't
want a funeral funeral he wanted like
let's celebrate i don't want everybody
crying here let's make it a life
celebration so
i don't know how well you know the
father but even listening to her
allowing her to like really at this
point her pain
of what she's going through is is way
more than any pain that you're going
through right now
right sure so like now it's the role to
go in and just be a supportive friend
and whatever she's feeling she wants to
cry
you'd be a shoulder to cry on if she
wants to talk about her dad and
lessons that um that she learned
you're you're you're listening you're
you're more
just reacting to what's coming from
there this is not your time to go off
and share you wanna come here and tell
us
you're on your journey and you're
growing like we're here to listen we
love it she's not ready for that yet you
know and maybe she will never get there
um but baby steps you're like you took
baby steps before you had a big
explosion um
yes
77 years worth
i love it and and not just for you but
again for everybody we all have people
who we wish would be more
understanding and growth oriented and
you learn things and you want to teach
them
all you can do is open the door they
still have to walk through it and they
open the doors you live you live in your
life
and you being with them like continue to
go and build and create and do these
amazing things and then go and just be
with them and sit with them and don't
give any advice until they're asking for
advice
and it will come because
when they don't feel judged and they
feel safe
it will come we'll say how did susan how
did you do this
how did you change it around and that's
when then you can start giving the
advice
thank you so much evan you got it susan
sending lots of love and thank you for
raising your hand really this time and
have a great trip out to see your friend
she's lucky to have you ray what do we
got be real quick with you uh if i cam
because i had like a long story i was
really gonna say but i'd rather just uh
go straight to the point um
i know one of your statements you like
to use is um
uh make sure that you build a lifestyle
and out of business and so it's
something i've been trying to like put
together myself and been going after
this entrepreneur for
a few years now i've been left my job
pretty much beginning of this year and
kind of like working this full time
um and it just so happened that you know
i pretty much kind of like build up a
skill with copywriting a little bit and
with just advertisements in general so i
was pretty much helping different
businesses out with the advertisement
and
uh over
uh i would say
maybe like a month or so ago i started
really doing some search soul searching
because i really want to make some type
of impact or empower some people because
i feel like i'm i feel more fulfilled
helping people out and having
them when they're stuck at a certain
point they're able to get them past that
barrier
and um
uh so the weekend just passed we had
like a family gathering and i talked to
different ones and he really had some
really deep conversations and they were
telling me about their situation they
was having and i was giving them some
input and some advice on what they
should do or what options they have
available for them uh even for the young
teenage kids that was pretty much
finished with school and stuff like that
and i felt like um
i was saying
uh i felt like really good body you know
saying i felt like that fulfillment that
you would have while you when i was
helping that person so
i started thinking that maybe i should
go into more coaching instead of like
the consulting side
but i was kind of torn because like i
don't want to step there and jump on
another because i have that syndrome the
shiny object syndrome and i don't want
to jump from business to business or
business when i know there's a lot of
opportunity available so i wanted to ask
the question how would you know
that opportunity is right for you big
decisions with your heart
and small ones with your head
so
you're not jumping to an opportunity
because it sounds good or makes
strategic sense a lot of times that the
heart decisions don't make sense
you know like for you to jump to being a
coach you may say it doesn't make any
sense like i didn't go to school for
this i trained in completely different
skill sets this makes zero sense
but if it's right in your heart you know
you're paying attention to the feeling
like imagine if you could actually be
great at that and how many people you
could serve and help as opposed to we're
not chasing opportunities
it's doing the thing that makes us come
alive
uh
so you know but when you're doing it
it's like how do you know if what's your
favorite food well you have to try a
bunch of stuff how do you know if you
like sushi well you try it and you see
if you like it and does it taste good so
you got a little taste of it this
weekend
and if you don't
chase that down in some capacity you're
going to regret it
you don't want to come back and say man
you know what back in 22 2022 i had this
opportunity and i never did it because i
was i was whatever i was too afraid i
was stuck in my business blah blah blah
it doesn't mean that you shut down your
business and go full time on just being
a coach when you don't know what you're
doing yet but it's spending
more time to pull on that thread to see
where it leads you
oh okay and when you're looking at new
opportunities
it's less of a like the opportunity
lives within like big decisions with
your heart and then you take your head
along with you so
there's lots of opportunities that i
could do
with what i know and skill sets and
connections but it has to be in service
of the mission
so i'm looking for opportunities within
you know on this on the tree that i've
planted
so i want to help entrepreneurs i want
to i want to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough and do that by getting
entrepreneurs making amazing businesses
right
there's lots of opportunities within
that but i care i don't care about
real estate opportunities and crypto
opportunities and like other businesses
that are just outside
of the mission that i'm on
so and and this were built to serve
might help or rereading it but it's like
what is the mission that you're on
who are the people that you desperately
want to serve that that even right now
may not make financial sense like you
don't know how you're gonna make money
doing it when i first started helping
entrepreneurs ray i thought i'd never
make money doing it i spoke at an event
at a ymca and three people showed up and
it was a free event
and i said i'm never going to make money
doing this because if i can only get
three people and it's free and the ymca
helped promote this i'm how am i going
to turn into business
i thought as a speaker well who hires
speakers corporations
what corporation's going to hire me to
come and speak like i'm going to go
speak at
at verizon and go tell all their
employees to go become entrepreneurs i i
just didn't think i would ever i'd never
make money doing this
right
but it was in my heart so i had to find
a way to keep going and then use
opportunities and strategy in my brain
to help me figure out how to make it
work
so at the beginning your heart and your
brain are usually not aligned because
your your head your brain wants to keep
you safe and practical and logical like
i went to school for this and i had
these skill sets so how does that all
map up but there's a problem you don't
love any of the stuff that you're doing
and the stuff that you love you don't
know how it's going to
make you any money
right yeah and so it doesn't mean quit
everything throw your business away go
all in on coaching and eventually figure
it out like i'm i like being practical
but you you can't just sit on this thing
that you love doing
and and not chase it down so it's how do
you how do you spend time
doing both
to get a taste of this thing
to start building some momentum towards
it to figure out what the opera use your
opportunistic genius mindset and apply
it to the thing that you love instead of
something completely different
so how can you turn opportunity from
coaching people whether that's
um
actually having them pay you to be a
coach whether that's live speaking on
stage whether you have book deals
whether you're doing deals with big
companies who are sponsoring you like
there's lots of
as soon as you turn your opportunistic
brain
and apply it to the thing that you
actually love doing great things will
open up
it's in the battle of like the judgment
of what do i do because this thing is
paying me and this thing i love
but then we get stuck and you most
people will get stuck on just doing the
thing that pays you
and then you know that like you're not
doing anything that you love and you end
up regretting it like if you look back
and you never spend another day coaching
people you're going to be you're going
to be 77 like susan and say man it's not
too late but i wish i had started back
in 2022.
you're right she's giving double thumbs
up on that one right so i mean you still
got lots of time you know if susan's got
lots of time you've got lots of time um
and so if i'm you i try to figure out
you know there's no perfect balance you
know how much time should you spend on
this versus that that's a that's a ray
question i can't tell you you have to
spend half your time on this and half
your time on that
you likely need to keep making money
from your business right like great well
as long as you don't completely hate it
keep going and building
but you need to spend time on this other
thing and use your opportunistic brain
to then help you build this thing
because this is where the magic is this
is where the money is ultimately this is
where the fulfillment is this is where
the happy life is where the impact is
like if you spent your time on that
thing you're gonna be way happier and
impact way more people and make way more
money than if you continued on the
business that you're currently running
that
it's just okay
you know it may be better than a job
but it's not like
filling your heart
with exploding energy
right gotcha
does that fit yes definitely thank you
so much evan really appreciate it
who's got something that uh i can help
with tonya's got her hand up what do we
got tanya yes hello evan hello everyone
so good to see your faces every week i'm
having this you know um
kind of like starting exercises about
how to share
my story like storytelling because most
of my life i've been you know i love
stories but i've been the listener not
really the ones that shares
so i'm kind of like
learning how to do it and um
[Music]
one thing that i find challenging is
because
when you share right and uh in and you
don't want to share specific parts of it
because any consideration personal
whatever consideration right
how do you feel like or how do you
manage that feeling of being less
authentic if you don't share them
you know
those those parts that you don't want to
share and not because you don't want to
share them because of you sometimes you
do it because it's not only your story
it belongs to someone else too and that
someone else deserves the right to tell
the story in their own terms and they
are not gonna have that audience
and uh you don't wanna you know you
don't want to own
you don't wanna put that person on the
spot yep if there was not you know
yeah
well first let's let's acknowledge you
because you you're sharing your story
right here
yeah like you're doing it
and i remember when you first joined uh
this group
the first
couple times you didn't say anything
never raise your hand you know zayn
zen had to pick on you and say okay
tanya
you gotta share something
[Laughter]
and he pulled you in and then here
i said hey guys let's just do a q a you
know and for anybody new here welcome
i'd like to have this group for people
who've you know got the book and have it
be resource and um you know do some
support in ongoing communities so you're
not alone on your journey and as soon as
i said hey we're going to do q a tanya's
hand is like the first one up
right what a what a change over the past
i don't know the couple months it hasn't
been that long
um so
you're already doing it you're already
way ahead of what you were doing before
you're already sharing this and it's
awesome
um
now inside of any story that you're
sharing
some of the things i'll always do not
always but often do is change change the
gender change the relationship if it's
somebody else
um because usually that doesn't matter
so in i mean the book that i just wrote
if i'm saying somebody's name
that you're you know you're one of the
readers for the beta readers for the
group um
i cleared it with them so there's a
really personal story about nina in
there obviously cleared it with her
before posted it i wrote it and then
uh i let her read it afterwards and i
think i wrote even in the book i don't
know if this is even going to make it
into the book
and and then i asked her the next day
and she's like yeah i just included it's
like you might want to read it first
and then she write it and she started
crying and she said no it's okay put put
it in
i talk about mark and i talk about
my agent steve in the book and i use
their names and i i
i wrote to them and asked them hey
here's what i wrote are you okay with it
being in the book and they both said yes
there's other people that i talk about
where
details minor details might change
gender might change the city they're in
might change because that stuff doesn't
really matter
um
and then for other people that you just
might have to
not talk about it you know there's lots
that i don't share about my parents
because they're very private people
so you know a couple stories um but most
of the stuff with them i don't share
and and i love my parents like they're
on my wall you know in front of me here
but because they're private and they
don't want you know content living on
the internet about them then i don't i
don't talk about it um
it's just knowing that you have enough
other stories
you know there's enough other things
that are happening that don't involve
other people or you can share your
perspective that still provide
tremendous value to people and and
even again back to what you just did
today
you raised your hand and what did you
share you shared that you were having
uh doubts or anxiety around
how do i share stories
yeah like you're doing it it's your
perspective without throwing somebody
else under the bus
i'm not in the throw people under the
bus
category um
some people might be it's like no like
that guy is a loser and i'm gonna let
the world know that he's a loser
okay cool like if that's your style go
forward but um
there's a lot you can share without
having to tell somebody else's side and
and i hear you it's their story to share
um
there's so many other stories that you
could tell that still gives a lot of
value to people
does that make sense
uh yes like i need to yeah i was doing
this kind of like
self-exercise about okay why do i feel
so uncomfortable or how can i manage
this should i
you know let leave this
storytelling at the side at all maybe
i'm you know not uh not that good at it
i don't know many thoughts and what i
end up concluding and you know what you
are doing
makes sense because probably i need to
to to to choose why what i want to share
and
why like not need to share everything to
feel authentic
that's that's kind of the thing right if
i don't share
some things would i feel less authentic
and uh well i need to find out what are
those things that
are
are good to share are fine to share they
may be difficult
but
at the same time won't affect anybody
else because that's the last thing that
i want to do right
so it's kind of like that exercise of
going over and over and see how can i
share my story what do i want to share
and why why do i want to share i just
want to start talking about something
just because i want more people to
follow me
no i don't want that i have a purpose so
i just need to find
what i want to share why and
i guess that little by little i find out
how you know
doing these exercises and trying to get
better i'll find how to share in like
more effective way
so yeah what you're saying yeah makes
sense you choose what you want to share
like yeah definitely
and that doesn't make me less authentic
right
yeah so like if you were going to share
a story of
of one of your students
that you helped
is there a student that like comes to
mind that has a story that there's a
lesson inside of
oh yes yeah definitely i can you know
yeah i have uh i have a lot of stories
of students and it's easier it's more
difficult when it's something personal
when it's something very close
you know like very you know when you
have to tap into your pain kind of thing
that's more that's when it comes more
difficult
but i mean it it should be more
difficult
yeah you know and and but like even even
with a student it might be painful
like maybe you let them down or maybe
they disappointed you or maybe you made
a mistake or
it could be you know a million different
things that potentially went wrong
um not just talking about the inspiring
stories but also some of the ones that
where you felt pain and then how did you
get through it are you still working
through it
yes yeah yeah definitely yesterday i had
one like
just yesterday yeah there's always you
know stories happening around everyone's
life right and yesterday i had a refusal
uh for one of my students
and uh you know i when whenever that
happens i you know i need to address and
talk and explain what happened and uh
husband was okay wife not so much and uh
you know it was at the end of the
afternoon i took this appointment at the
end of the afternoon and because i
wanted to talk to them i wanted to
address as soon as possible but you know
she said something like you know she
should be more enthusiastic about
reapplying she was harsh like you know
it it is when i have a situation like
this it's hard for me as well because
it's i put a lot of work on it and it
when it doesn't work sometimes most of
the times work
sometimes it doesn't
so it's hard on me too so i heard i
heard say
she's saying that until it hurt it hurts
right but she was like well she at least
she should put more excitement on trying
to reapply
and uh i understand her situation i
understand her position but at the same
time it's painful for the person because
we're we're not uh kind of like
infallible machines we are and it's not
my mistake it was not my mistake
sometimes it happens it's their
situation which is not ideal and you
know sometimes that happens
but i'm dealing with uh the with the
frustration it's hard
it's hard and uh and uh you know let's
see what happens with them like
hopefully i can turn okay so how did you
deal with the situation how did it make
you feel and how did you deal with it
at that point it was almost 6 pm i was
with my energy very low
and
i recognized that she felt
she felt probably dismissed like i was
not really
feeling what they were feeling
so i told the husband i tell look i
understand
how frustrating is this because it's not
just a no to a paper it's a no to a
dream you have
and
but we we set clear expectations from
the beginning so you knew that this
could happen
so it's not that i'm not enthusiastic if
you want to proceed and reapply we will
and you know we will do the best uh we
can
and uh you know it's not that i don't
feel your pain so i that wasn't as much
as i could do my energy it was not
you know like probably i could do
something better but
that's what i managed to do at that time
and with you know that
mindset so think about that story
what would the lesson in the story be
there's a lot of different ways you
could take it
what's the lesson for people in that
story
the lesson is that
sometimes
you
have to deal
with
a negative outcome
regardless how much effort you put
sometimes happens
especially if it's not under your
control
but
probably what i would say is important
is to be upfront from the beginning
so there is no like
major damage beyond what you know of
course the disappointment and the time
and those things
it's uh it's it's hard when these
situations happen for people it's very
frustrating and they react different
ways that's the lesson
that's something everybody here can
connect
to the details of the story
don't matter
like the the person's name doesn't
matter the person gender doesn't matter
what they're hiring you for
doesn't matter all that matters is you
were trying to do something for a client
and you didn't get the result that they
wanted
and
they
made you feel really bad with a with a
with a comment out of frustration and
how it made you feel and then what you
did afterwards
you could tell that story
like you can tell that story in two ways
you can tell the story like you told us
and you can include the name you can say
hey
you know jose you know was my client who
hired me to do this and it got rejected
and and then his wife said this person
tiny doesn't care like you can go into
all the details
but those don't really matter as much as
the summary is you've got a client
who
is not happy with you and said something
mean about you
out of their frustration
at the end of a really long day
like how do you show up
so what really matters inside that story
is how did it make you feel
and then what did you do afterwards
so when they say hey tanya
it doesn't even look like she's trying
the most important part of the story is
how did that actually when when she said
those words how did that make you feel
i'd have you've been putting the effort
and the work and you're trying and you
do this and we set expectations and
then they said this and it just like
that's the most important part did it
crush you did you cry did you need to go
meditate like what those you know words
like but if there's no emotion to it
then then it's not really a story worth
sharing if you can just brush it off and
get back up then it doesn't really
matter but if when something hits you
like say that did destroy you say those
words like
just crushed you
then that's a story that you can share
without
naming the client or if they watch the
video they may not even know it's them
like it doesn't have to reference them
you could change the gender
it doesn't matter what they're hiring
you for all that matters is how the
situation made you feel and what you did
afterwards that's the lesson so in
telling a story if i'm going to tell a
story
about zen there's lots of stories i
could tell about zayn
you know it's like well what's what's
the what's the outcome that i like
what's the lesson i want people to have
and then i can tell the right story
around it and i don't even have to have
it as
like if there was something that was
going to be
you know if if uh
you know zayn zan and i met up in vegas
last week or last month and uh
uh
he he was supposed to wear a mask the
whole time this is a good full this is a
fun one uh his wife insisted that he
wear a mask the whole time and he didn't
wear a mask
you know for almost any of it
and so it could be it could be about
environment like why well because he's
in a room where nobody's wearing a mask
and it feels awkward and uncomfortable
to be the only one wearing the mask and
and so he told his wife that he was not
wearing the math and so
i could make that about environment like
the environment you're in really matters
if you're around people who are doing
the things that you want then
you're more likely to be pulled up but
if you're around people who are living
the way that you don't want
or is against what you said you would do
it's a lot harder to stay consistent
and
i wouldn't tell that story about zayn
publicly on my youtube channel
you know i i would i the fact that he's
here and you can hear me say it and it's
in like a fun group we can i'll do that
but uh i wouldn't share that story as an
example on my youtube channel without
him hearing it
um
but i could still share that story about
i could i could change it up he's like i
was at this event and i was i met an
entrepreneur who said that she wanted to
wear masks the whole time
and
and she promised people in her life that
she would and then as soon as she came
out she didn't you know like she was
walking around without the mask on like
wait what happened like well nobody else
is wearing a mask like you just changed
it up without identifying zayn changing
gender say the entrepreneur like it
doesn't matter that it's zan
right um there's very few circumstances
where it actually does like if it's your
mom or your parents or something then
maybe there's something really deeply
personal it's like it'd only be them it
could only be them
um
you know there's abuse or something like
it can only be them um
but most stories you can easily flip
around because the point is your how you
felt in your journey through it not so
much about the specifics of the person
anyway i hope that helps tanya and we
went we went along on it but i think
it's valuable for others who are kind of
struggling with with the same thing and
definitely i struggled with too and what
i'm saying is not
it's simple but it's not easy
especially when you're diving into like
the the emotion of how it made you feel
the most important thing if i was going
to tell the zan story about
um environment
i'd have to connect it like i would make
it even stronger for me how did it make
me feel
am i am i
upset that he's um
not doing it am i
am i upset that am i disappointed myself
for not being a better
role model should i have worn a mask
like whatever no i don't actually care
enough about it it's just more of a
funny story but if it like how does it
impact me
is what makes for much better story
so how does it impact you that creates
like that emotion that you have is the
thing that's worth diving into more than
the specifics of what happened in the
story
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love